Batman vs Superman trailer just dropped
just found out just got my cellphone on
a read comments about it holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] yes you need to calm down is it
really surprising that the most powerful
man in the world should be a figure of
controversy we as a population on this
planet have been looking for a savior
name we're talking about a man whose
very existence you're not telling us the
truth challenges our own sense of
priority in the universe human beings
have a horrible track record of
following people great power
an absolute power corrupts absolutely
half maybe he's just a guy trying to do
the right you know better now don't
matter Devil's don't come from Hell
beneath their warrior they come from
school the world has been so caught up
with what he can do that no one has
asked what he should
that's how it starts the fever the rage
the feeling of powerlessness but turns
good men
cool
Wow it's the Batmobile hey all right
tell me do you play
holy [ __ ]
you gotta watch that [ __ ] again isn't
really surprising that the most powerful
man in the world should be a figure of
controversy we as a population lot on
this shot have been looking for a safe
mark in love - we're talking about real
one worshiping Superman system shot so
he's absolutely priority did the
universe human beings have a horrible
track record of following people with
great power an absolute power corrupts
absolutely half maybe he's just a guy
trying to do the right rear better now
don't Devil's don't come from Hell to
meet the warrior they conference the
world has been so caught up with what he
can do that no one has asked what he
should
that's how it starts - beautiful this
film locks a fever the rage the feeling
of powerlessness but turns good man
cool
some news seriously
I even knows that the
Rockman you look so good at shine
got the white eyes tell me do you plead
Olmo yeah this is not happening but it's
happening
just watch the Batman vs Superman
trailer this is a dream come true holy
[ __ ] man how many times have we heard
over like the past two decades that we
would be getting a Batman and Superman
film possibly they've actually done it I
love the way it's being shot Zack Snyder
has gone from like Man of Steel crazy
handheld to actual like solid beautiful
visual imagery like it has more that
Zack Snyder touched that I kind of
thought should should have been in Man
of Steel a little bit more I like the
whole world of everyone worshiping
Superman viewing him like he's a god but
it looks like beautifully dark it looks
beautifully haunting I like Alfred's
narration I like that shot that we get a
Ben Affleck where he's just staring at
his bat suit I wonder what he's thinking
he probably thinks he looks really good
in that suit he was probably getting an
erection while looking at himself in
that suit I love that shot where Batman
just sort of comes up and he's probably
looking at Superman at that point it
just looks so badass I love this suit I
gotta admit I like the suit more than
the Dark Knight suit man it looks really
[ __ ] cool and then when Batman is I
like the voice I like how it's not
totally it's got like the perfect level
it sounds like he's got like a robotic
thing going on to change his voice a
little bit
tell me do you bleed I'm still doing
Christian Bale I can't help it but no
the film looks [ __ ] amazing
I love the imagery I cannot wait to
watch this on IMAX I am so [ __ ]
excited people holy [ __ ]
Wow this review has consisted of mainly
swear words of excitement if you're new
to the channel you can totally subscribe
to the real rejects and you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
we're where I'm about to have a heart
attack oh god I'm so overwhelmed with
joy right now god I'm like sweating all
over again this happened with Star Wars
I'm like [ __ ]
papi is great sup you little shits my
youtube channel is youtube.com slash
sullen blaze a [ __ ] shout out would be
really moist right now especially at a
hard time like this and by heart I mean
my penis K bye sullen plays is a man
with a very small penis and when it gets
erect it is possibly four inches
that's what Solan plays mainly consist
of he is sullen he masturbates for the
camera most of his videos get flagged
for inappropriate content but the few
that get up are pretty entertaining now
this looks like it's a movie channel
that he actually has he probably still
masturbates